a possible change for mask guidelines at  local conventions an emergency directive  from governor steve sisalik allows  convention goers organizers to ask  visitors if they're vaccinated if they  are they don't need to wear a mask this  only applies to conventions with 4 000  attendees now we spoke with one attendee  who says the downside is the potential  economic implications of banning  unvaccinated vendors  personally i'd prefer an auteur mask  but on the other hand  i would like to have every retailer who  needs to attend that show attend that  show  well these rules are similar to the  large event mask exception that went  into effect last month proof of  vaccination would not be mandatory for  all conventions just for those that  choose this option